hey reject nation how you doing happy
Saturday Marvel Studios has released yet
again another TV spot for Avengers
infinity war you mean there's more
footage there's more let's see guys I am
about 80 pages shy of finishing the
Infinity Gauntlet comic book I am so
excited for this infinity war movie now
that I'm reading source material I can't
wait to see Memphis ito I can't wait to
see mistress death Silver Surfer
she-hulk Adam warlock Doctor Doom all
the characters are coming together right
now oh yeah and I just could not be more
anticipate I get why people give you
crap when you don't know the source
material because of how much is gonna be
represented in the movie I'm excited you
know cuz I'm 80 pages away from starting
this book that's gonna be really
integral to my enjoyment movie let's see
this I was called chant
[Music]
we're gonna need some help dang buck ooh
oh boy hang nice
[Music]
Avengers Marvel humor Marvel
acknowledging fish-out-of-water type
thing maybe a little product placement
for Starbucks store getting that
Starbucks money this might be my
favorite TV spot this is the most
exciting TV yeah cuz it has that war
vibe about it yeah yeah and it actually
lets a couple of these moments breathe
in a satisfying way it's like it's most
of the scenes that we've already seen
glimpses of but I feel like just a
little bit of extra additional stuff
from me like seeing Bucky and capper
reunite which I'm really happy for that
they get to do that why does Tony have
sunglasses
he's like Iron Man suit though I think
he's morphing from a regular outfit into
it like I think he just how he's gonna
do one of those briefcase things yeah
that's the whole thing with Iron Man
there's always a new way he morphs into
who's gonna watch now yeah you can see
Cherie using her weapon at one point in
this TV spot this does remind me of what
I pointed out I don't know which
reaction we did it for but I remember
saying that I'm surprised they haven't
really been putting black panther in
front and senator with all the hype
going around with black panther being
biggest domestic box-office gross of all
superhero movies I kind of feel like
they haven't really been putting him
like front and center this trailer this
is a black panther vibe you know what it
also piggy backs directly off of a plot
point from black panther the movie like
directly dashing how close the proximity
is what it's like we opened up what
Conda I was like oh if you haven't seen
my phantom ass couple months that tells
you right there out and see how
themselves are like hey if you ain't got
up by now you know I'm super excited for
this movie man how we already got
tickets to two screenings I really love
the way they're handling these trailers
they keep cutting around to the same
scenes and then just showing like
expanded moments of that I imagine that
there's probably be a lot more scenes
that we just haven't even seen a tease
of just yet they're handling this
marketing very well
I'm super
I'm very excited to see what we haven't
seen any of ya this is such a black
panther spot I love it alright guys well
what's been your favorite TV spot thus
far you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell and
check us out on patreon full-length TV
show reactions weekly Q&A is would love
to have you become a patron Oh Chuck
Todd